welcome to hari sadhus the chana where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at why the i7 8700 K
isn't really worth it and why rise may
bring 12 cores
onto the mainstream platform with their
third generation CPUs but before we go
into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming at the PCs so
what's the problem why should you not
buy an 87 K the main reason that you
should avoid buying the 8700 K right now
is because there are a lot of CPUs that
are coming out in the very imminent
future that will beat out 87 RK in
performance while not costing much more
or even costing less the main CPU that
is going to render the 87 or a pointless
is the 9700 K or the 8800 K which is the
eight core 16 thread CPU that is
expected from Intel later this year some
chips from AMD that can make the 8700 K
pointless would be first of all the 2800
X if AMD decides to release that next up
their flagship of the third generation
will also completely obliterate the 80
some hundred K even if it still sticks
to being an octa-core processor it is
expected that AMD will allow its users
to overclock to 5 gigahertz and as a
result 8 cores and 16 threads is 5
gigahertz will definitely beat out 6
cores and twelve threads at five gears
on top of this it may be possible that
aimed you will go on to 12 cores even 16
cores with their third generation of
processors so either way
AMD's new CPUs coming out next year or
the 2800 X if that comes out will
completely destroy the 87 K so it
doesn't really make sense to buy it
right now first let's take a deeper look
at the 9700 K or the 88 okay leaks have
already started coming in for this new
CPU and at first the first Lake
suggested that this CPU would have a
base clock of 2.6 here Hertz but soon
after there's another leak that changed
that and suggested that it would
actually have a face clock of 3.1 game
Hertz
in my opinion I think that this CPU will
have at least a base clock of 3.6
gigahertz because that's what the 78 20
X which is also an octa-core processor
from Intel has and as a result I feel
like they will match that base clock or
even beat it so that's what I think
Intel is probably trying to make 9700
cake more power efficient than the 78
20x which consumed 140 watts but no
matter how much power this new 97 or K
consumes it will definitely be out the
82 Merc a because of its extra 2 cores
and 4 threads so what about overclocking
how high can this new chip overclock
well I would like to say the Intel will
be able to take it to 5u Hertz but that
does seem a bit hopeful but no matter
what I'm pretty sure Intel will be able
to offer us at least four gigahertz and
they will probably offer four point four
gigahertz or above because I doubt that
Intel would want AMD to beat them out in
overclocking speed the 2700 X has an
official overclock speed of four point
three five gigahertz so as a result
Intel will probably offer 4.40 Hertz or
four point five eight Hertz after
official overclock speed but users can
probably overclock it to four point
seven or four point eight yards and if
we're lucky maybe even five years so the
performance of this new CPU looks great
but how much will it exactly cost I
think that Intel will position the CPU
in the 400 to 450 dollar range because
they don't want to completely obliterate
their 87 or K in price base the MSRP of
the 80s of RK is 360 dollars so it
double have to price this new CPU at
least $40 more than the 8700 K for it to
still make some sense to buy the 8200 K
they don't want to completely make it
obsolete
ask for motherboards these e 390
motherboards will probably come in at
180 to 200 dollars so the 97 RK with its
motherboard will probably cost around 50
to $100 more than the 80s and we're okay
with its motherboard so as you guys can
see it is much more expensive
but the thing is the people who are
considering to buy the 8700 K right now
don't really care too much about price
and they just want the best performance
available
so once the 9700 K comes out everyone
who wants the premium performance will
just shell out the extra money and go
for the 97 or okay and everyone who is
more budget conscious will just go for
the 2700 X from AMD so as a result 87 RK
is just right in the middle and no one
will really buy it so that's why the
eighties of Merck a is going to become
pointless very soon and any of you guys
who are considering to buy it right now
should just wait for the 9700 k but that
will probably suit your needs much
better anyways moving on to the next CPU
that will make the examiner decay
pointless and maybe even a 9200 k
pointless is the flagship of the third
generation of rising we already had
rumors that the third generation of
Rison will offer at least five gigahertz
and now we're getting rumors that it'll
offer 12 to 16 cores and knowing AMD AMD
will most likely offer a really good
stock cooler on top of all this while
offering a really great price so at this
point even the 9700 K doesn't really
make that much sense so why are some
news outlets suggesting that AMD will
bring out 12 cores on to the mainstream
platform with the third generation of
rising well here's the reasoning after
the 9700 k comes out Intel will match
Rison core four core and most likely
Intel would beat them out in clock speed
now AMD isn't really known for clock
speed and so Intel will probably always
have the edge there if they're matched
core four core so for AMD to take over
Intel AMD would have to include more
cores while still maintaining a good
price so that is why some news outlets
are suggesting that AMD will bring out
12 cores outside mainstream platform the
next generation some news outlets are
even suggesting as highest 16 cores but
12 seems much more believable even if
AMD doesn't go up to 12 cores
it is expected that AMD will bring up 5
gigahertz overclocking speed with their
octa core processors next generation
even just that will
match if not beat the performance of the
97 of her okay while also being at a
much cheaper price with the stock cooler
not to mention that it can work with
older motherboards which are much
cheaper than with 97 or cable work so as
a result it really doesn't make sense to
buy the 8700 okay right now place 97 RK
is gonna come out very soon and that is
gonna beat in performance and after that
Rison will probably be all of these in
performance and price and so that is why
the 87 RK is quite worthless right now
overall till now Andy dominated the
value market while Intel continued to
dominate the performance market however
with the release of rising to AMD closed
the gap within toe in terms of
performance and ami is starting to
dominate both the value and performance
market this is forcing Intel to come out
with an 8 core 16 thread processor for
the mainstream platform very soon and
that new CPU will pretty much render the
8700 K pointless on top of this Andy
isn't done with closing the gap next
generation they're pushing on to the 7
animator process while offering 5
gigahertz or even 12 or 16 cores because
of all this I recommend that if you guys
are considering to buy the 80s 700 K
right now and you guys at least wait for
the 9700 K because the 97 RK is gonna
beat out the ISA market completely and
after that rise in it will probably
offer even better value so as a result
AMD is bringing out great value and
doesn't really make sense to buy Intel
CPU so just make sure to consider all
this when you guys are deciding which
CPU you guys want to buy so what do you
guys think do you guys think that Intel
will continue to lay back and let a me
just take them over or do you think that
Intel will finally compete with AMD in
terms of the price make sure comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this view then make sure couple
like and hit that subscribe button if
you guys would like to see more videos
just like this one but until next time
bye
[Music]